hola bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta nueva emisión nos
acompaña la licenciada cecilia cep ella
es psicóloga sexóloga además es
escritora es autora de los libros sexo a
tr a todo ritmo y también del libro
carnaval toda la vida
junto a ella vamos a abordar diversos
temas vinculados a lo que son los
vínculos sexo afectivos el erotismo el
goce y también el deseo sexual
hablaremos de la manera en que nos
vinculamos con los otros pero también
con nosotros mismos se sigue hace
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 muchas
gracias
cecilia muchísimas gracias nuevamente
bueno comencemos hablando del deseo
sexual no hay una pregunta clave que
surge es una construcción social
cultural digo porque en lo que es el
imaginario colectivo pareciera estar
mucho más ligado a lo que es del orden
natural no lo instintivo quizás mejor
dicho la pregunta debería ser creo que
es de natural y que de cultural en lo
que es el deseo sexual cecilia
y qué difícil que responderlo cuando no
tenemos punto de comparación porque la
cultura nos atraviesa constantemente y
creo que hay una contradicción en que
decimos hay un mensaje que en realidad
el deseo es algo natural cuando
constantemente estamos bombardeando en
mensajes sobre lo que decimos que tiene
que ser el deseo y lo que vemos es que
muchas veces lo que vemos en la clínica
es que casi gran parte de las
problemáticas tienen un trasfondo social
y mucho de lo que se construye a partir
de lo que escuchamos y de lo que creemos
que nos tendría que pasar
y ya tenemos un deseo que es normal que
nos hace sentir bien pero entramos en
conflicto porque leemos en algún lado
que tendríamos que desear más o menos
antes quiero aclarar a nuestra audiencia
estamos viendo algunas imágenes que
pertenecen a la cuenta de instagram de
cecilia así pueden ver su arroba estamos
hablando de mensajes ilustraciones todas
frases referentes a los temas que
estamos hablando y que son muy
interesantes
cecilia bueno esta pregunta está aún
bastante vinculada a lo que hablábamos
previamente no vamos a hablar ahora de
lo que son los mandatos y las presiones
sociales no que afectan a todas las
personas a todas las identidades
mandatos sociales que por ejemplo nos
hablan de un hombre siempre dispuesto a
tener relaciones sexuales no una suerte
de cazador mandatos que también crean el
relato de una mujer pasiva a la hora del
sexo no receptora o que está más en
busca de amor a diferencia del hombre
también existe esa idea de que no tener
deseos sexuales como algo anormal
cecilia contanos de dónde vienen y qué
efectos tienen todos esos mandatos no
bien el problema es que como tenemos tan
poca información adecuada sobre
sexualidad por la falta de educación
sexual que hay en general estos mensajes
sin ningún fundamento científico
aprenden muy fácil en las personas
porque no tienen información adecuada
para contrastar entonces es enseguida se
generan los mitos que circulan que se
creen como verdades y esos mitos están
muy sesgados por cuestiones de género
entonces todo se hace como un gran
malentendido y el precio es justamente
en la calidad de vida porque la gente a
partir de estos mitos y la poca
información que tienen genera malestar e
incluso genera disfunciones sexuales en
esto de creer que tengo que responder
que tengo que estar listo se genera una
ansiedad de desempeño importante se
generan conflictos de pareja porque
pienso que mi pareja masculina siempre
tiene que querer esto no tienen
insisto no tienen ningún fundamento y lo
que vemos es que esto es muy se ve mucho
en las consultas por lo general las
problemáticas masculinas siempre están
asociadas a un problema de
empeño y eso tiene que ver con este rol
masculino de que tiene que cumplir
entonces las problemáticas se ven en
la dirección y el tiempo de duración o
sea la performance que es el gran el
gran fantasma masculino en poder llevar
la relación sexual adelante carga con
esa mochila y en las mujeres lo que
vemos son problemáticas siempre
asociadas al deseo porque siempre
estuvimos en un lugar de objeto no de
sujeto entonces tenemos dificultad el
deseo dificultad en el goce y esto que
hoy por hoy tenemos que es una mirada de
género para interpretar y para releer
las problemáticas y empezará a decir no
esto es una problemática es una cuestión
de género entonces el camino nosotros
absolutamente hablabas hablabas de el
goce de cecilia y hay una idea muy
interesante que planteadas y que creo
que puede ayudar a muchísimas personas
te voy a citar a orgasmos se aprende de
sigo no nadie nace sabiendo no harías
una aproximación cómo se alcanza cuáles
son los principales aprendizajes que tan
necesarios son
bien primero sacar esta idea de que el
sexo es natural no porque pensamos que
lo que vamos a nacer sabiendo y la
realidad es que todo se construye y todo
se aprende cuando hablamos de orgaz
mirar que me gusta porque es que lo
tomamos con un verbo activo como me hago
cargo hay personas que viven sean
orgasmos de manera espontánea y natural
en el sentido de que es algo que se les
da en la infancia o que lo aprenden de
alguna manera más casual y hay personas
que por por su historia por una historia
más la crianza más conservadora lo
tienen que aprender más de adultos y
para llegar a eso necesitamos tener como
ciertas ciertas condiciones yo yo es
decir que siempre que yo me exija algo
que yo esperé que algo suceda tengo que
pensar si esas condiciones están dadas
para que suceda entonces necesito cierta
información cierto conocimiento de mi
cuerpo de anatomía de los tiempos los
tiempos es muy importante porque a veces
uno le pregunta a la persona bueno pero
cuando estás allí intentando tocarte
conectar
tiempo que tomas para esto porque si no
suceden 10 minutos la persona se
frustration piensa que tiene un problema
entonces tiene que haber un escenario
posible de tiempos de conocimiento de
predisposición de conexión con el cuerpo
y de estimulación adecuada mucho por eso
decimos que es un aprendizaje por
estamos sumar ciertas herramientas para
que suceda así es silvia hay un concepto
que también desarrollados y que bueno
como el previamente de lo que hablamos
previamente también es muy interesante
es a veces uno encuentra palabras que
describen algo que uno vio toda la vida
pero que no había encontrado la palabra
vos hablaste el síndrome de la persona
ambulancia es muy interesante contanos
de qué se trata por favor ese término
viene de de la psicología que se está
tendencia por ahí más en lo en los
femeninos de salir al rescate de estas
venimos de una historia familiar donde
hubo alguien en la familia que estuvo
enfermo que que tuvo la atención y bien
entramos en ese rol
yo tensión tengo una formación sistémica
de psicología y después me formé en el
modelo sistémico entonces tengo esta
tendencia a analizar todo en función de
las relaciones en el contexto la persona
ambulancia en la que siempre se va a
sentir bien en un rol de ayuda a un otro
entonces generamos a veces estas
relaciones en base de la necesidad y
salimos al rescate y tenemos siempre la
capa de superman o superwoman y
relegando lo que nosotros sentimos lo
que necesitábamos como siempre muy en en
pos del otro y esto tiene un costo a
nivel de vínculos de sexo afectivos yo
siempre digo que esas personas son muy
buenas para desarrollarse en ciertas
profesiones como la medicina la docencia
pero hay que buscar repetir esto en las
relaciones íntimas no hacemos
seguramente muchísimas personas se van a
sentir identificados o identificados
identificadas perdón con este síndrome
que está describiendo cecilia ahora
también existe algo llamado la brecha
orgánica no estamos haciendo como una
suerte de repaso por varios conceptos
que son bien interesantes digamos se
trata de una suerte de ranking no en el
cual los hombres heterosexuales son los
que más orgasmos tienen las mujeres si
es hetero son las que menos órganos
tienen y lo curioso cecilia que vos
marcadas también es que a nivel
masturbación no existe en esa brecha
esas diferencias como es esa brecha
contanos y por qué se da esa diferencia
en lo que es a nivel masturbación
en un término desafortunado para el sexo
femenino no estamos de acuerdo lo que se
vio lo que se estudió es
evaluaban cantidad de orgasmos por
encuentros sexuales en función a la
población población heterosexual
población hombre gay población mujeres
lesbianas población bisexual y mujeres
heterosexuales y lo que vieron es que
puntuaban más alto los hombres
heterosexuales los hombres gays luego
las mujeres bisexuales y en último lugar
las mujeres heterosexuales que cuando se
evaluaba capacidad orgásmica a la hora
de masturbarse no había diferencias
hacia todas las personas alcanzamos con
el mismo la misma eficacia los orgasmos
cuando nos masturba moss el problema
está cuando hay un encuentro entre un
hombre y una mujer por qué porque acá
vamos a hablar también mucho del impacto
y la responsabilidad de la cultura de la
pornografía porque lo que se observa es
que cuando hay una un protagonismo del
coito es decir del pene vagina de la
práctica de la penetración los orgasmos
en la capacidad orgásmica la mujer baja
porque esto es importante decirlo porque
no todas las mujeres alcanzan el orgasmo
en penetración de hecho las estadísticas
dicen más o menos
de 5 el problema es que las relaciones
heterosexuales los encuentros se basan
en como que la escena principal consiste
en el coito y eso hace que las chances
del orgasmo de la mujer bajen
es decir lo tenía que continuar
y hablamos por eso a la hora de la
masturbación la mujer por ahí nos
recurre a una penetración recurre a la
fricción y lo que se observa es que
tiene más capacidad orgásmica con la
estimulación manual con el sexo oral con
la fricción de la vulva en penetración
no tenemos la estimulación adecuada
durante el tiempo necesario eso hace que
haya tanta diferencia de orgasmos en los
encuentros que nos queda aproximadamente
un minuto pero no quiero dejar de
hacerte la siguiente pregunta que tiene
que ver con que existen otras formas
además del sexo no de vincularnos
eróticamente verdad no sólo es sexo es
la única manera de vincularnos no
creo que tenemos que ampliarlo cada vez
más pensamos muchas veces que el sexo
justamente hizo la penetración los
genitales y nos estamos olvidando de
todo lo demás que la experiencia sexual
es una experiencia del cuerpo entero
pero que además es tenemos la fantasía
tenemos el diálogo hasta yo te diría que
el humor entra él en este que cuanto más
lo ampliemos más rico va a ser y menos
frustrante y menos exigente
cecilia se te agradezco muchísimo se ha
pasado rapidísimo esta entrevista
seguiría dialogando contigo muchísimo
tiempo más muchas gracias
no por favor hasta luego ya nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y también en
france24 punto com sigan con nosotros
[Música]